okay so I thought I'd do a quick X look
because it's been a little while and a
lots been happening so those of you who
follow me on Twitter or on Facebook will
know that I've been that away and busy a
lot I was actually out of Exeter for
more on June than I was in next so I was
off in Germany on the chapel tour I was
off in Birmingham giving a talk at the
wrong Meteorological Society student
conference about my PhD research and
cheese I think I might actually be in
addition to you know I was finished and
Jersey so the first the chapel blog has
gone live if you haven't seen it it will
be I'll include a link on the screen I'm
so so happy with how these videos are
come out there's two more big vlogs
coming and I think there's like the most
fun thing I've edited but you know I'll
let you be the judge of that studio
please get bored and I know I said that
I would vlog the conference but I
decided not to you excited I figured I
physically I thought about 25 different
aged ended at the moment because I got
stuff for this channel I've got stuff
for the SBC Oxford mile college channel
I've got stuff for Durrell to edit
that's just so much to do that I didn't
want to add to that work list it's dead
if you have any questions about the
conference because I didn't vlog if you
want to ask me something about it please
in the comments below hopefully you now
know to turn on your Colin replies but
you know I had a good time at the
conference I actually was asked to write
an article for the wrong music illogical
society magazine based on my talk which
is you know hey and people seem to enjoy
at the time and it was great experience
for me so yeah getting over the PhD it
feels like well talking about my PhD the
actual science Pasadena HS the scientist
guy okay I had a really good meeting
with my supervisors yesterday where we
would sort of talk about applying my
thesis because if you don't know at the
end of the PhD you don't reset an exam
per se what you do is you write thesis
which is about a 200 page document the
details all the scientific work you've
done in your PhD includes background
literature review that kind of stuff but
also the original site that you've
contributed so if quite a big daunting
prospect to write and the idea of
filling out your technical chapters
because you have standard you know you
have the introduction have the
background chapter then you have about
three chapters also where you bring out
your technical results and your
theoretical work and you justify it
another kind
and then you have something again which
can be a bit flexible but like the
actual meats of it that technical stuff
is quite intimidating to say this is
what I want to do because you're not
used to doing that you know you're used
to in education as we told this is what
you're going to learn it's give me this
and this and this and a PhD is daunting
to start because you actually have to
determine what you want to look at but
it's even more daunting when you're
writing it up because you're sort of
trying to say to people I think this is
worth adding to the scientific
literature I think what I'm doing is
worthwhile so actually talking to my
supervisors about that yesterday I'm
having that okayed was a really really
positive step so thumbs up from me for
the PhD so far on the subject of PhD
videos actually I I'm going to be
uploading a series of videos like a
stratosphere crash course which I said
I'd do a little while ago but I did not
like because I didn't have time to do
them properly I've now set myself a
schedule you might have seen on Twitter
where it basically said that they're
gonna be coming out every week from the
8th of August through to the 22nd of
August so that's gonna be like a weekly
just just just three videos so they're
gonna be quite long talking about an
introduction to that parasites talk
about strategy and talk about my
research so if you're interested in that
stick around
between those videos they're hopefully
going to be videos about what the dole
done so like talking about species going
extinct why they're going extinct why
disease still exists which I really hope
will be thought-provoking hopefully two
videos a week though it's quite
ambitious but I'm gonna see if I could
do it too summer whilst I have the time
and there's lots of singing actually on
the subject of Durrell I don't know
maybe YouTube screwed up on this one but
I loaded a series of vlogs about my time
in Dhahran the first ones got like three
thousand views and the rest of them got
less 1000 I'm not sure why that is
maybe the subplot screwed up maybe
people just aren't interested if you
haven't seen them playlist is like here
I did four videos in total and I am
really really pleased with how they came
out they are they look great I think and
I really enjoyed my time there so if you
if you would like to see me looking
happy or if you like learning about
unusual things like animal conservation
and me being clean up my tamarins then
go and check it out because it was like
the best experience of my life so yeah
if you I don't know maybe maybe people
just aren't interested and maybe I'm
just like please validate me but yeah
that's not the case then go check it out
I think they're great
the last thing I wanted to talk about in
this video was
a service called patreon now you might
be familiar with it you might not it's
basically like an extension of the
Renaissance patron system where somebody
like a nobleman it was rich would pay
for an artist like sale in our the Vinci
to do works of art if it was somebody
else to write poetry or something like
that they they would be their patron
patrons like that with youtubers so
people pay money either on a monthly
basis or on a video basis to creators
that they really like now I'm not on
this service it's something that I know
some people do because they like getting
rid of the adverts on the video which
let's face it are really annoying but I
don't know if it's a part I want to go
down just yet feel free to contribute to
well you know if you would her this
feels very douche-baggy but like if you
if you would be interested in like
supporting me on patreon put down the
comments I'm not just gonna turn it on
be like yay give me your money because I
wanted listen to what you guys say you
are such an amazing community and I
respect you way too much to just try and
pump you for cash I wanted to talk about
patreon because I basically started
supporting some people recently and I
realized that maybe you don't know about
these content creators and I think
they're like the best things on YouTube
so you know let's share so the three
things about supporting on patreon are
crash course
scishow and every frame of painting now
crash course you're probably most
familiar with because I talked about it
in some other videos it's basically like
online education for free across a range
of subjects and there's you know world
history there's they're doing economics
at the moment there's physiology
chemistry you know it's it's just an
amazing educational resource so I'm
supporting that on a monthly basis and
scishow is kind of like the science
version there but it's more science news
than science education and they have
different branches like scishow space
scishow kids and I think it's a really
valuable addition to YouTube so I'm
supporting that in addition to those two
there's a fantastic channel called every
frame of painting now I am a massive
film geek I one day want to make films
myself and every favorite painting is
literally the best thing I think I've
ever found on YouTube it's a series of
video essays done by an editor where he
looks for concepts throughout films and
that was one recently on chairs for
example I think there's another one on
Jackie Chan there's another one on
Michael Bay it's if you like film do
yourself a favor and check it out I'll
put something up on the screen because
it's lit
really amazing I fangirl so hard but I
found this and I'm absolutely delighted
to support it on patreon so if you would
like the sound of these channels or if
you watch them at yourself then maybe
consider to support them on patreon
because I think as a YouTube community
we should try and bring up the people
that are the best and produce their pub
the best content in terms of high
quality in terms of how engaging isn't
just about innovative it is people who
make that level of content I think
should be rewarded and given that
they're effectively putting it out for
free it's kind of amazing than they do
in the first place
so I'm doing this as a method to try and
keep them to stick around on YouTube so
maybe go check them out yourself that's
it for me in this video a slightly
pointless kind of rambling update I
really hope you enjoy the video coming
out soon because my god the editing is
practically killing me and I will see
you around our vlog again in like a
couple of weeks by the end of August for
sure and stay safe until then leave your
comments about patreon down there and
anything else in fact if there's
anything on your mind just put it in the
comment section because I love getting
comments I never get enough on my videos
because I'd love hearing from you guys
you amazing beautiful intelligent
audience I never hear enough from you so
please talk to me talk to me thanks for
watching and I will see you in a couple
of weeks